my guest tonight very funny comedian who
was a cast member on star night live and
starred in weeds
and man with a plan uh don't turn back
turn back
please welcome our good friend kevin
nealon
listen
you're so needy as a performer you were
turning back to the camera
during your introduction you were about
to be on a single but you had to be part
of that too didn't you
i have been doing this for many years
i'm experienced i know where the cameras
are
at all times yeah i know there's one
right behind me watch
yeah and there's one over here yeah and
guess what what i also have a hidden
camera right here that you don't know
about
oh nice so you're you're filming this
yourself yes yes
i have another show that i do it's
called conan's show
by me it's footage you take when you're
a guest on my show
and then you put this out online i got
to tell you something you got a minute
uh yes i was chuckling as i was driving
down here
tonight because i remember i was at a
party either you had it or i had it or
maybe it was even on your show
all my memories of you just kind of
blend together i get it so this clearly
this event meant a lot to you
not really i didn't think so and um i
was wearing a v-neck sweater without a
t-shirt underneath it
and it triggered you for some reason it
did you wouldn't let go of that
for months after that whenever i saw you
so i can't believe you were
the v-neck without the t-shirt under it
yeah
i don't know what the trigger was or why
that was
you have a very this you're a very
good-looking guy very very
good-looking but this area of your body
not so great that's my best quality
no and you what i don't like is when a
guy wears a low-cut
v and no t-shirt it looks cheesy to me
even with the chisel pecks one pack was
chiseled the other was no i chiseled
both of them
before i got there i made sure they were
both chiseled you know i'm going to tell
you something i
i've i'm going to i'm going to
compliment you at the very top of this
interview and i'm going to say this with
great sincerity you're going to have a
hard time with it
look at me in the eye then when you say
it i'm looking you in the eye and i'm
telling you
that you are one of in my opinion one of
the great
all-time talk show guests you're
fantastic
you think differently you always come
with amazing jokes you're very funny
uh and you have been a blessing to all
the different shows
i have done and i always wanted to
compliment you up front
because i'm going to grow irritated with
you very soon
and uh i'm probably going to just cut
out of the interview fast
so i wanted to get that out of the way
and i appreciate it all my writers
throughout the years whenever you're on
the show
my writers don't watch the show they've
got better things to do than i don't
crap
they gather around the sets when you're
on yes they consider you
an absolute comedy master and i'm i'm
just uh delighted that you could be here
as we sort of wind this nightly thing
down well you have always and i'm not
just saying this because you said
something nice to me
you have always been a pleasure to be on
your sh
it has always been a pleasure to be on
your show because you are
always open to my ideas trying different
things
different bits and then you have good
writers and you yourself contribute
you add on to it and i always walk away
thinking that was funny
and in my um highlight reel
your show is like right up there
what do you mean write it don't say
right up there no it's right up there
that's a compliment but that could mean
right up there with all the other shows
you do
that it's it's vague enough to
to leave me wondering what does he mean
by right now what i mean is this and
it's a compliment
i threw your name in the hat with some
of the other talk show hosts
and the hat that's right up there on the
top shelf it's top shelf
is what i'm saying it's your top shelf
you know this is going to be a
spontaneous chat there's no
prepared material here we never prepare
we're like magicians we're like
magicians no magician
magicians prepare it was a bad analogy
terrible that was a bad enough
the worst analogy magicians andy who
prepares more than a magician
i mean you're both creepy if that's what
you're talking about
we don't prepare at all we're like
surgeons anyway
but you know i do want to talk to you
about some things that have been going
on in your life that that sound
uh what like major events for example
you got robbed
recently your home was robbed
it's funny how you would know that but i
didn't tell anybody
i got some great stuff from your house
that's what i meant to say
but no this is a true story you and i
are friends and you told me that you got
robbed recently
you and your lovely wife were robbed
that sounds terrible well we weren't
home at the time
right so it wasn't that terrible yeah we
um
we were gone for three months last
december i know that sounds like one
month
but i'm talking about the two additional
months after december as well
okay so that let's recap that's three
months okay
and you made that unnecessarily
complicated let me finish
and somebody broke into our house and i
don't think that this person had any
remorse at all because my wife isn't
into positive affirmations
and signs she has signs all over the
house like you're exactly where you're
meant to be
you deserve what you have you know
no risk no gain so this person i'm sure
didn't you know
this kind of just supported his actions
yeah
um you think that this robber broke into
your house and saw you're exactly where
you need to be and thought
i within my rights exactly no no risk
no gain read all these signs your wife
helped this criminal steal from you it
might have been my wife i don't know
[Laughter]
so what was taken well that when the guy
broke in um
he got cut on the window so he left
splatterings of blood
which was kind of creepy on your house
so we had forensics come in and
take some samples and just run some dna
tests
yeah and when i say forensics i mean
some of the actors from csi
and so we're looking for those results
and we expect to get them back during
sweeps
you idiot so um so
the guy that broke in now i say it's a
guy i don't be sexist it could have been
a woman
so this [ __ ]
took some personal things of mine
you're so woke i appreciate that so um
he took a couple of watches
sentimental some things that were
sentimental to me that didn't take much
kind of in and out pretty quickly
and uh he took like a watch i'd give him
to my father that was engraved on the
back and then a watch that was engraved
on the
cartier watch from lorne michaels after
i left snl
actually oh that's i took that from
lauren right
so you stole it from me i stole it from
so you know
that's that's got to feel terrible yeah
such personal items taken but
and this might sound kind of crazy to
you but the thing that he took that
really upset me the most were um
i was good friends with gary shandling i
know and um
i got some of his ashes um that i had an
urn that i wear on my neck sometimes and
that was in with the watches
so um wait a minute the thief don't tell
me the thief took some of the gary
chandling's account
the weird thing about it all is that
that gary shanley gave me those ashes
before he died oh for cuts
isn't that crazy i don't even know what
that means
how does that happen i mean that's love
i'm curious um this has been a very
weird time for all of us
thank you people that no i said
i said for all of you okay okay sorry
what i mean is uh and and i think
especially it's been very strange for
people that routinely go out in
front of crowds and entertain i know
that's a big part of your life out there
trying to get a laugh
and all of us doing what we can
what are you doing in this downtime are
you watching stuff what are you binge
watching because that's what i've been
doing for most this down time
is binge watching like crazy um i've
been watching uh i've been
watched just about every show on
television
today i was actually binge watching our
ring doorbell footage
from the past few months and yes you
went through all of it yeah yes
our ups guy is hilarious and so actually
i actually saw our
our burglar who is also very funny
he's got a funny walk i haven't seen his
face but
uh yes i've been doing that mostly
and i've gotten into photography oh
that's interesting how did you get into
photography um i got a camera
and um used the one on my phone
and i bought some frames yeah yeah and i
you know basically i've been taking
this is actually been taking provocative
pictures of my wife
oh and she likes me doing it as opposed
to some creepy photographer
because she knows that i'm not trying to
sleep with her
[Laughter]
she's right here the cardboard cutout
she's right here having to listen
to this uh absolute [ __ ] that you're
spewing
you're a saint by the way you're a saint
i don't know how you put up with this
guy because
um no one else will by the way i've
slept with every cut out here
as a cutout yeah yeah as a cutout yeah
uh yeah um
you know you asked me about what else
i've been doing during the pandemic but
i i you know i've been getting into
these
audio books and i've been listening to
woody allen
uh that's right woody allen came out
with his audiobook
his it's his biography i propose him
nothing
and i hadn't heard him in a while i
started listening to his his book on
tape and
he sounded so old and also i thought he
maybe he might had a stroke
because he was slurring it seemed like
he was slurring his words
and i was telling everybody i think
woody had a stroke you know and then i
went to my doctor for physical or
something and i played
it for him just to get a professional's
opinion and he goes he definitely
has had some kind of a neurological
event huh so i just continued telling
people woody had a stroke
and then i realized that i was playing
the audio book at two times slower the
speed
than it was supposed to be
so i fired my doctor because i realized
she is not very good
but i continue to spread the rumors do
you ever
think to yourself kevin always no
i always i never share my thoughts with
anybody
do you ever think to yourself you know
back in the day you were
a struggling comic you know you were out
there yeah
working so hard just to get noticed
and um how much life is different now
well i think it's the same for both of
us you know we both came from
nothing and we both came from
you know i don't i don't know salt of
the earth
i don't think i came here from nothing
my father had a very
talk show and i just inherited him
[Laughter]
my father had late night with conan
o'brien when it was on the radio and
then i just inherited it and i was like
a father
thank you you know i've done this show
more times than annie richter has
what are you talking about that's not
possible it's true probably you know
what i will say
i don't know if you remember andy but i
think you were there at our first show
in 19 on september 13th 1993
uh you were still doing snl i think and
you came down and you sat on the floor
i came down and sat on the floor right
in front of you on the like below the
desk
i was on the desk at first but they said
no you got to get up
because you couldn't see the camera but
you were there it wasn't the first show
i was sitting right there and you're on
the floor yeah on the floor and i was
watching
and i saw like every mistake right from
[Applause]
there
well this is good this has been a nice
shot i hope you've learned something
from our little chat here today
nothing i don't think i've ever learned
anything from you but
i've always enjoyed you i enjoy you very
much i really have a good time talking
to you seriously i really appreciated
everything you've offered me and
everybody else you brought on a lot of
young comics on your show
which they were really grateful i'd
always heard people talking uh comics
saying
they did their first shot on conan and
that's going to stay with them for the
rest of their life
it's a nice feeling my first shot was
johnny carson
you know so that's what stayed with me
you're more of an afterthought
but still i appreciate you i'll take i
will take a backseat to johnny carson
any day now i'm going to be really
serious with you i think you did a great
job
i think you were one of the finest talk
show hosts out there because you were
different
and you did bring on a lot of people and
you you created a situation
especially for me where i felt
comfortable and i could try things
and be risky and um
and um and you had an amazing run and
you're not going to stop you're going to
be doing podcasts or whatever else
no seriously look at the end you said
wherever else like
landscaping no podcasting
you'll be doing something else a podcast
landscaping
i'm going to focus on landscaping uh
kevin
so nice of you to say that and sincerely
you're one of the all-time greats and
i'm so grateful that we're friends after
all these years
i mean i've known you after all these
years since i met you at snl
and you were so nice to me then i think
i met you
in 1988. i met you in february of 1988
when i started in snl and you and dana
carvey walked in the room and right away
you were just a gem of a fellow to me
and you guy you came on with conan with
uh greg daniels
both harvard graduates all right nerdy
okay
kind of googly-eyed okay let's wrap this
up
the point is smelly go ahead wrap it up
uh
wonderful you said i had one of the
greatest talk shows of all time
insecure send on that note kevin i want
to thank you for being here enough with
the googly i never had googly eyes
oh i want to thank you for having me
here let's not mix things up
okay oh thank you for you didn't have to
have me here
no i did yeah you went out of your you
didn't go out of your way but you called
and texted every day
yes i had no choice you may harass me go
out of their way
you harassed me and i had to have you on
kevin nealon
first of all god bless i'm ending this
you hate to say goodbye don't you
goodbye that's not how you say goodbye
farewell you're not even looking at me
i'm not going to look at you you're not
looking at me kevin you've missed say
goodbye kevin conan i love you
i love you and i love you conan you're
not looking at me